[Music]
with s AP and Google I am they mean
Johnson have been an architect with what
we call the Google business unit within
sa P since last September so we've
established a good working partnership
along with a go to market partnership
and today's goal is hopefully to cover
everything that's top of mind with
everyone from our customers as well as
our partner community and before I start
anything I have to give my safe harbor
statement because I do have some future
forward-facing documentation in there
and such but beyond that let's see this
is what we're going to endeavor to cover
we have a lot to cover in 15 minutes or
so
I'm going to try to see if I can leave
time for Q&A I'm gonna go through the
current Enterprise drivers ie what is
the requirement hour in the business
from our customers that drives this kind
of innovation we're gonna look at the
intelligent suite or intelligent
enterprise architecture how s AP brings
those components together and then the
next point being how we look at the
technical footprint on how that
intelligent enterprise functions within
the GCP framework and make use of GCP
services and then lastly we're gonna
look at some example use cases and again
some of these are prioritized some are
prototypes I've been developing with our
customers along these lines so I'm feel
free to think of some questions so I was
like I said I don't think we've got time
to do interactive sessions we're gonna
have one afterwards so what do we
already know I think from the point of
view of that artificial intelligence
machine learning IOT instant insights
they're all requirements of the business
world as well as a consumer world
nowadays the other aspect is that it's
taken for granted always expected that
the embedded machine learning and
analytics
needs to provide that built-in guidance
or even automation at the enterprise
level and then the last one is the
conversational applications it's the new
experience
new user experience so it said does that
mean that all the UX designers are out
of work now I don't think so but
generally it's the way to go forward and
that's something we're going to also
discuss how s AP and Google are working
together to provide that into the
enterprise world ie taking the Google
home experience into the enterprise
itself so when I talk about the
intelligent enterprise or the
intelligent world I like to go back a
couple of years and talk about this I
won't tell you where I started on this
little timeline you can just guess but
it is quite far back but it is on there
though so that's it looks very good
we've gone through these many iterations
as you can see at the top you know you
see all the traditional architectural
frameworks that started off on the
mainframe client server go to cloud
mobile etc and now we in turn internally
call the intelligent technology server
area the ones below that it's kind of
interesting to note as well forget the
technology look at the enabling
technologies there as you can see
everybody's familiar with those things
and I remember the days of when I was in
when I started in this computer industry
back in back in the 86 s and late into
the 90s you went to work and you
actually had the latest technology
because I had an IBM XT to make use of
it Lotus 1-2-3 and all I had in home was
a vic-20 vic-20
home computer and then come to the
modern day and it's kind of switched
you're finding that the consumer has the
latest tech and the enterprise is still
the lot is now the laggards so that's
where we're looking at in terms of how
we're trying to bring this the
intelligent technologies to bring it all
the way down into the customer value
creation as you can see here we want to
be about the intelligent enterprise
meaning that is beyond just automation
it's beyond just that what we call the
digital transformation and making
everything in real time so look at this
and like say tell me something new one
of the things I always like to talk
about is the fact that the core back-end
systems are now engaging at the edge the
gentleman asked me am I going to be
talking about CRM and supply chain in
the up
yes the big difference nowadays is not
in the back office is in the front
office now actually it's beyond the
front of it it's directly in the
consumers hands and most of the time the
other aspects of this I talk about is
the rate of that which you can redefine
or redefine or refactor the back end is
inversely fortunately the complexity and
backend systems are complex so that's
where the conundrum is really sits there
and then lastly expectations X or
expectations an experience matter going
back to that consumer expectation of
being brought into the enterprise
obviously actually it's nothing new but
it's worth restating that because in
terms of what we're trying to do here is
to kind like make all of these things
which are impediments and turn them into
opportunities of how we actually now
make use of these technologies to
empower the business so with that this
slide is a very short summary of how si
P looks at the intelligence suite or
intelligent enterprise it's you may be
familiar with the classic scenario as a
bimodal RIT where you have the
back-office functions and then you have
the accelerating innovation layer so
what I like to refer to this is really
looking at the got the back-office
capabilities and how to steer the
company how to run your company and
those are traditional ERP that's
obviously the hunt solo for the DNA from
sa P from 40 years of developing
hardcore backend course enterprise
applications the now tricky is now to
pivot from all that information and make
it from front side sorry consumer
phrasing and going more into the other
right-hand side of the equation
ie engaging at the edge and making the
innovations happen and a much faster
cycle so how does this ap look at doing
these things so it's a bit of an eye
chart it's just to show the breadth and
depth of the solutions that sa P brings
to the table so this is the traditional
capabilities from all the way from the
customer experience through
manufacturing people engagement and
spend management so I think I'm assuming
a fair number of you gonna go
back to the hotel or Friday if you're
professional like me and do your
expenses on concur now so this is that
you know we cover a full spectrum of
interactions within the enterprise
application space and the big difference
from our point of view is the fact that
we've seen the need for all of this to
work seamlessly together to create that
end-to-end flow and as you can see down
here we targeted or Kali that's the
intelligence suite but in order to have
a fully functioning intelligence suite
we have to provide those integrations we
have to provide the master data and the
orchestration and the Business Objects
there is not Business Objects the
analytics its Business Objects meaning
the business object I am I am a business
partner you're an employee a sales order
is a business object because we're going
to talk about how in the intelligent
enterprise you're going to actually
invoke and consume business services
derive from those Business Objects the
the thing that I'm going to now if we
look at this sorry go on about the
intelligence suite well what's the
underlying constituents that make up the
intelligence suite so you can see here
the top layer which is all those
business solutions that I explained some
are traditional on-premise in areas what
we call our digital core they started
life back as an ERP system is now
transformed into the main component
called s4 HANA s4 HANA obviously runs on
Prem as we have a cloud version as well
and just like you know our customers
they're running that version in the
cloud on our ass providers such as
Google cloud platform which is now fully
certified for those solutions along with
all the other line of business solutions
that are traditionally have been more
SAS based how does this all become
connect cohesively into the intelligence
suite as you can see here there's a lot
of technologies involved in the middle
there the traditional stuff there
gentlemen Australia it's it all about
machine learning yes it's all about
machine learning is it about a
conversational or AI yes
is it about real-time analytics and
data-driven decision making you know all
of that yes and but that's a bucket of
technologies and a bucket of
technologies that is evolving
and developing very very rapidly and as
I mentioned before the problem with
enterprise applications is generally
speaking is the ability to pivot very
quickly it takes a lot of time because
there's an intrinsic built-in
interdependencies of business processes
it's not easy to just change it on the
fly here because that change can have a
tremendous ripple effect down there so
the problem is how do you now make use
of the innovative technologies in the
context of that enterprise applications
and that's where we're really looking at
leveraging that digital platform so as I
mentioned that's really the front side
intelligence suite now if we look at
this in an architectural component style
the core of enabling that from a CP
point of view for our customers is a
thing called a CP cloud platform so this
is the core engine that enables the
brokering of our enterprise capabilities
into the world of digital services beer
from GCP services or anybody else's
services for that matter but based on
the you know obviously for my from my
point of view as you can see from my
t-shirt I have a slight bias in the way
I'm working obviously I'm working with
the the Google cloud teams in terms of
integrating their technology into the
business functions within the ASAP
business applications the three area are
the four areas that you can see here the
enterprise or the connected enterprise
scenario that's the traditional Business
Suite components I just talked about
insight driven activities so as part of
SA P as when I mentioned the core tech
enabling technology that we developed
call sa P Hana which provides that in
memory database that powers our
solutions provides both analytical and
transactional in the one instance so the
traditional way of doing business of an
OLTP moving the data route and doing
analysis is really going away from all
from from the SA P world in the
operational world for our customers and
that's where we're talking about that
the business ready and so again it's
ready from the point of view is like you
know is it ready for consumption and
cannot can the business users have that
consumer grade interface again rather
than the green screens that they were
used to and on the top right the native
class
of course this is all about the
traditional stuff that comes to mind
when you're talking about native clock
you know containerization web-scale and
all the other things along with it at
that point I'm not really gonna get too
much into it because the the the si PE
aspects about cloud native is relative
it's related to the SI p centric
development I'm not gonna say that you
need to go and build the next greatest
web app consumer app on our platform was
as Google's platform because that's not
what it's designed for you you can't
absolutely do it but the benefit really
comes when you're looking at using the
two in the enterprise context so this is
just another can I quick a list of the
specific functions and capabilities that
are behind these areas and what we're
going to be talking about really today
is really along the lines of the
connections aspects on the left hand on
the left hand side as I mentioned it's
the connected Enterprise at the end of
the day your apps our customers partners
apps are going to be all about running
somewhat disconnected mode but fully
integrated mode it's the fact that it's
got to be loosely coupled is the way to
go forward and one of the key things
that everybody has to make sure is when
you're talking about this intelligent
enterprise apps is synchronization and
usage of the data so the master data
governance ISKCON it's absolutely
important and thirdly secondly sorry the
aspects about the the governance
framework the one thing that every seems
to pass on is that we have all these
beautiful machine learning algorithms
making decisions and one thing that is
required in the enterprise world is a
audit trail why was that action taken
now that's something that sa P as an
enterprise applications when to have at
their heart and soul the fact that we
audit everything we can find out why did
this number become this number and the
reason behind it now think of this and
extrapolate this to you've got 500
algorithms running and making decisions
and changes so now knowing what the
decision of this algorithm that was made
should be depend upon whatever
constraints it uses the time of making
that decision it is not like I'm sorry
it's not like
and user clicking a button now we need
to have the context so we will look at
enterprise applications using artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
governance framework has becomes very
important as well these are the
high-level the capabilities built inside
the s AP cloud platform and you know
when you're looking at this you're
thinking well yeah okay I got all of
these in my native GCP components as
well and some of her absolutely
complimentary and I have overlaps so I'm
are I would say even competitive in
straight out of the box but it's the
fact that what we talk about as an
enabling technology to power the
business applications is how you
leverage these capabilities together
with the GCP services it's like I said
I'm going to go into the use cases but
this is a important aspect of enabling
the enterprise apps into the new era
because as I mentioned before it is very
difficult to turn every single
enterprise applications into 10,000
micro services because of the huge
interdependencies built into the process
from a procure of a process there are
thousands of dependencies just inside it
alone outside it so can we now extend
and make use of the PICU to pay you know
as a business unit as a function yes
it's called like procurement in the
crowlike we have with a RIBA but when
you started if you try to now decompose
each of those individually becomes
harder and harder because of the inter
dependencies you have that but our goal
here is really to see how this platform
can broker that new innovation the new
technology at the lowest level whilst
maintaining the business integrity of
the process itself and that's why we
have created a whole slew of use cases
or what we call the way that we envision
and I'm say we envision because it's a
way that we designed it doesn't mean
that our customers and our partners
really end up making use of it that way
because once somebody's given a
particular tool they can make it do
anything they want one of the first use
cases is
as I mentioned experience and user
interface matters nowadays the green
screen is not the way to go
so one of the key things that we also
did is power
as part of our cloud platform it's a
sinkhole as if you fury cloud which
allows you to create a basically it's an
html5 base
Givi framework there front-ends all the
business transactions now I'm working
with Google as one of our customers and
you can imagine Google has they have
some expectations on UI and I believe
they have some experience in designing
UI so they're like this is great Damian
but we use this system it's angular and
we're like okay so you don't like our
cool new front screen all UI screens you
want to use your owns and develop yours
guess what the way that we've
architected this and broken it is
allowing them to do that so they're
actually implementing things that you
know they release the skin that you gave
me forget that here's my angular based
Java Java angular based a skin I want to
front-end it to the business processes
so all of these things that we did to
just enable and start exposing that are
being reused by our partners and
customers the other part of this
framework is key is the extensions in
the traditional ERP world and not just
SAV you had to basically modify the core
code and that got rolled out with a
version upgrade as new capabilities came
in that was the pain that mercy is CTOs
as well as business leaders lived
through as part of the upgrade process
and what I ended up happening was a lot
of the times people were just upgrading
the technical aspects to make stay
current on on support but I haven't
really updated any of my business
processes so even though I have got a
current system I'm still running it as
off ten years ago so that's one of the
problems that were there and one of the
frameworks that we've developed for our
platform is to get yourself out of that
framework
I mentioned the bimodal IT concept back
of his functions those business services
business objects are there to be served
up
but how you now consume and extend that
is done natively through what we call
the SAV cloud platform and that's one of
the use cases that it's predominantly
used by our customers as well as our
partners this other one here this is an
interesting one because I can actually
say we got there first
to Google because we actually developed
and realized that API management is key
to our need for consuming the business
eight applications and developing what
we call the the Business Services in the
end of the day we owe a m'd in to our
platform apogee so Apogee is the our API
management tool which is obviously now
the Google owned API management tool and
it provides and the reason for doing
that as they realize this also it's the
fact that we need to have this govern as
I mentioned API structure into our
back-end citizen services and again this
becomes one of the key reasons we use
this mechanism to power the intelligent
enterprises because as developers as
partners I don't expect you to know what
it takes to create a purchase order and
them and the gyrations that you need to
go through necessarily in the purchase
order creation process or what the
business the customer has defined as
mandatory fields
mandatory process requirements and what
workflows get triggered on the backflow
all of those things are actually
configured and managed within sa P but
as a front from the point of view of
developing or extending us out so just
give me a restful service that says I
can do a an ADD mode into a rest service
and that's all you need to do you know
and you use the you know JSON based
packets or whether it's XML that's the
beauty of what we've done here is the
fact that the complexity of the back is
now really hidden or you provide we
provide a facade for you to consume the
backend business functions the other
part of this
it's the IOT and the extensions
framework this obviously is built into
natively into the ASAP world because I
say PE as I mentioned as this as a
preeminent phenomenal business
applications provider hundreds of our
customers probably thousands of our
customers have extensive IOT
needs so we developed our own
application sweet capabilities built
into the Hana club essa Peka
cloud platform now in the GCP world i
think i was just talking to develop a
across the road they were using the GCP
IOT core now the question came to me was
like can you integrate that with our iot
capabilities because they want to now
extend and make use of our enterprise
asset management because within the IOT
framework is not the simple part is not
actually a simple but the capture of IOT
events by itself is half the story
it's what where did it come from what
action needs to be taken from it all of
that information is guess what it's in
our enterprise asset management
environment so the integration of GCP
IOT core into cloud platform IRT is
absolutely feasible because we've got a
messaging bus we can integrate into
pub/sub as the messaging MQTT based
message bus that the IOT core uses last
one here as i said this is the one i i'm
kind of like yeah you you have the
options of doing all of this this is
just to show that up from the SCP point
of view we have the flexibility for you
to develop you know native cloud native
applications in a microservices based
architecture because we're using the
Cloud Foundry model so all of the
runtimes and languages available from
the Cloud Foundry framework is available
natively the benefit for this is again
as I mentioned is you have the
flexibility now to develop brand-new
applications that extend the CRM that
extended the supply chain using the
full-blown services architecture that
you're familiar with that's web native
or cloud native but still invoke and
update the back-end processes which at
the end of the day I mean I'm waiting
for the day that we can I can truly say
that every single s for Hana ERP service
is a business service and it's delivered
as a micro service that is going to be
very difficult it might be because
there's a lot of dependencies and is
more efficient to run it the way we're
doing it right now this one is just to
give you an idea of what what I would
consider to be
I don't want to say a reference
architecture buddy because I don't
capture every single scenario but what
this does show is you know there's
something that our customers are already
doing which is running s4 and other
business on-premise applications on Hana
in GCP as you saw the couple of
announcements that came out this year
Google it's caught up with the
competition and it already has four
terabyte ohana a virtual Hana systems
available they're also now leading the
pack in terms of providing obtain a
chipsets supported in infor Hana as well
the other part about this is also is the
the ASAP cloud platform that I mentioned
is certified to run on GCP as well so
not only is the business applications
now running on GCP our platform is
running on are in the GCP and over here
obviously you have the native GCP
services so that everybody is making use
of as a developer out there and this is
where the interesting parts happen and
this is where the all the interesting is
talked about as this intelligent
application comes to the forefront I did
that and I did this like this just show
you the interactions right so at the end
of the day a couple of developers came
up to me and says well can I just write
my service straight into sa P and as you
know in any world you know given enough
time and resources yes you can but it's
a question of why would you do that
right because at the end of the day if
the the things that we have going
directly as you can see into s4 and Hana
are things related the data aspects
because you want to be able to pull into
bigquery data directly from the ASAP
systems and that's what we've supported
as part of our capabilities with our
partnership but if you look at the rest
of it more of the interactions that the
business tier the easiest way to do is
to have it brokered through the SCP I
won't call the cloud platform services
why because the SCP services understands
everything s ap centric and as much as
you know we like to say that you know
I've got that simple restful service
there are implications on still putting
there P o in and then in fact that Oh
you now have to look at the contract
information things like that there are
various AP centric scenarios hidden
behind there in the business services
function so rather than doing an update
over to directly overt on that side and
then worrying about having to
orchestrate all those updates we've
already done the orchestration at this
tier so from an external consumption of
services that's the way it paths to go
because that broke us out and allows you
to now make use of those technologies
and capabilities as it's a case
important I won't go into details later
on some of the AI capabilities from here
we actually had a session yesterday
talked about the fact our Deloitte as
partner has created a invoice entry
screen leveraging the aik buddies from
the DCP stack write it brokers in calls
in the necessary Furio data service and
consumes it and puts the the invoice in
so he's mimicking oh sorry oops sorry
that's my IT I'm afraid I can't I can't
change that time-out session security
security sorry what was it go that was
what you were telling me thank you sorry
anyway so where was I so that's the
reason why we're looking at the the
brokering aspects of cloud platform and
then if I get down into the technical
architecture what I did I and I got a
big camera here it's conceptual design
scenarios only right because there's a
has on future state of future scenarios
but this is to give an overview of how
the actual brokering consumption
services can really operate because it's
got things like I didn't even like I
said I didn't even put in the cloud
three so IOT core on GCP that's in there
but things such as all the machine
learning you know the vision API and all
those things I want to talk about
building a new app all these
capabilities that come from the Google
cloud platform all of the Big Data stuff
over there on the left-hand side right
and then also some of the course
infrastructure
as such as the kubernetes the
containerization and was the compute
engines if you look at this the way that
can like it fits together is to kind
like identify the areas where the
connections occur so the big data
scenarios guess what we have a component
as part of the comp cloud platform it's
called data hub it's been 35 we gated
the details here that works hand-in-hand
with bigquery and data proc and other
data prop forms on GCP what does it do
it brokers that service directly into
the business applications on the
integration side so cloud pub/sub is the
way to go from most integration
scenarios in the GCP world we've got the
ways of integrating into that at the
messaging layer we have enterprise
messaging built into cloud platform we
actually OEM SOLAS as our pub/sub
framework inside us but we also have
native integration services as I said so
good old-fashioned restful services are
oh I shouldn't say yeah I guess it's
right yeah restful is old-fashioned
there whatever the next wave comes in
but soap race web services etc they're
all provided and we have thousands that
you probably know we have these things
going inside si pico do you think it
shorter from the point of view of
different services invoking our business
functions they can now be exposed
consumed through this layer we have the
aspects of the copilot so one of the
things that you're gonna I want to talk
about it also is I've showed it here
with the G suite integrations we
actually for our sapphire session I'm a
we we announced and showed how we've
integrated sheets the first wave into
the ICP applications now the the reason
why I said you know this is like we're
trying to have a single thread through
to the integrations in areas so if
that's the way we're looking at it and
you can see all the hair here on the
extends to the SAS for in their line of
business ie if we're going to create a
conversational bot we don't want to
create one for this application one for
that and pretty we want some of that
publication more than development it's
the fact that when
we're looking at the conversational
aspects it has to retain the business
context so as the conversation flows
through it can start off in our C for C
sorry C C for Hana Hybris or customer
engagement scenario and could
theoretically end up in a finance
conversation in our finance system
related to billing inquiries so because
of that we want to maintain that context
and that's why we have what we call the
ICP copilot which now makes use of those
machine learning capabilities from our
Leonardo functions and those same Li and
other functions is what can now actually
integrate into all the Google brain and
ml and caml e functions intensive flow
so that's to give you a high-level view
of the technical scenarios that it comes
together and so what I wanted to do is
to talk about a little bit more about
what we've done you know hard in
concrete terms everybody knows is all
about the data the key areas of govern
manage and enriched and consumed so at
the end of the day I want to explain
something I had in the previous slide so
when we look at the consumer manage
aspects and and enrich this is a
scenario that's now in it's been
released into working this is a way that
sa ps4 HANA can now basically have an
interconnect with Google bigquery as
well as a pubsub frameworks as well as
GCP machine learning frameworks via the
cloud storage so in here is as AP data
hub which manages the flow of data and
orchestrates that that data hub also now
normally just pushes data into and reads
from and manages the overall
orchestration but theoretically if you
are a GCP user and have already made use
of extensive data flows guess what it's
a question as my previous diagram I
showed you it's about reuse so again the
core principle here is making sure that
that the technologies available in GCP
are now fully integrated into the
business functions of s AP because one
thing you don't want to do in s AP
especially in general in the RP and
price applications is just do data based
updates
it's got to be at the application logic
layer the other things that's key
importance is experience and ease-of-use
as I mentioned so from the ASAP world
we've basically released and have
available key technologies that allows
you to do all these things from the
personas aspects for people and then the
technology as I mentioned the machine
learning libraries as well as an
rest-based API this is what the Google
team is free skinning via the rest based
API into the business functions that
we've exposed as well as on the business
side obviously the integrations I
mentioned about the G suite as well as
the title integrate tighter integration
to G suite through those copilot
functions we have this is a probably not
relevant for GCPs
in the world in in the crowd but this is
part of the way the whole suite of
solution says that comes from the along
for the ride as part of the sa p cloud
platform to allow you to do things this
is where a lot of the things I mentioned
before there might be an overlap within
the specific functions then you might be
using TCP to do but again it's the this
is the s AP centric view but the point
is that you can now broker these
services into those external GCP
services without having to relearn on or
real and learn the the intricacies of
the s AP context the last one in offices
for every that's relevant for most of
the people these attendees here is
looking at the way we look at machine
learning and artificial intelligence the
key difference from sa P's world we are
at a world leading technology provider
and this is what I started off saying 20
years ago but it's a question of our
technology was developed to power our
business applications at the end of the
day the technology is about the business
outcomes it's an innate technologies and
enable for us it's not a technology are
not a technology company by itself we
saw all about developing the right
technologies to power the business
applications and the business processes
and that's why when we look at this and
say the way that s ap address approaches
machine learning and AI in general and
any of the innovation new generation
innovation technologies is with the
business context in mind with the
business outcomes that our customers are
expecting so when I look at this
when I talk about the machine learning
the way that we have attacked and
started to consume machine learning is
to provide that core foundation enable
enablement we provide the industry level
context so when we're looking at
blockchain when we're looking at fraud
detection in the financial services
world when we look at customer consumer
interaction in our retail world we look
at using the relevant machine learning
algorithms technologies that way same
goes for within the procurement side in
sourcing so it's the industry context is
supplied by us it's not a generalized
you know algorithm out there in terms of
what we want to look at it and the
consuming apps and again our consuming
apps are our business applications so as
I mentioned things such as in our
financial world the way that we apply
cash it's now available via automated
scenario from a machine learning so it's
the apps are our business applications
themselves that's really the really
context from our point of view is the
consuming apps are our business
applications and then the last one there
is a bring your own so we have customers
we have partners it's definitely got
shorter from point of view have
developed your own machine learning
algorithms and perhaps have your own
models so the way that we've architected
our solution a technology stack is the
fact that you can bring your own to the
you know and make use of that so that's
the same way that we had like I
mentioned up one of our partners
Deloitte bought their own machine
learning algorithm to model to do the
invoice creation from a scandal OSI
image looking a little bit at the
details behind this from the fact that
we can now also announce as with Hana to
service pack for five I believe we can
do what's called do native tensorflow
serving so what this depicts is the fact
that within my ASAP Hana world I can
make a call out to tensorflow pass it
the relevant information and have the
inference engine give me back results
and then the other side of this is that
we can now using data hub and all the
data management to
with NSA piana moved the relevant data
over to GCSE which is cloud storage
which then is now used by the cm le
engine you know on the tens of
processing units running that retraining
that model using the on-demand compute
power from the TP use and feet updating
that new model so you can have that nice
little confuse training functions
applied and you can also obviously with
this tune the model as and when you need
depending on that depending on the data
outcomes at you having the and since
this is a dev session I thought I'd
better put a bit of code in there so
this actually is the code to I don't
know if you can see this here sis call
sis FL and wrapper procedure the FL is
the application function library in
slide HANA so to show you it is real
this is where it's making that call out
to the tenth of a tenth of serving
engine and you're getting back as you
can see here it's doing a predict and
what it's doing is this one this version
allows you to send in multiple values or
an array for prediction example use
cases as I mentioned I think it's going
to be key here this as I meant sorry I
didn't mention so if I get into the
example use cases as part of the
partnership we've actually developed
brand-new solutions with Google first of
which is a solution called SCP data
custodian and it's probably imagine this
this actually came out of I would say
Google and themselves made it made it
relevant because in the old ways of
where you used to deploy s AP and then
other enterprise applications you would
have to deploy multiple region in
regional instances because of the
communications and the you know
segregation duties and all of those
things now with Google's high speed
interconnects across the globe you could
theoretically have a single instance
scenario but the downside of the single
aim scenario because the gdpr there is
all of the who's got access to what data
and why they doing it that way so that's
the solution that we actually worked
with Google using their technology in
terms of access control lists and
security and seeing the logging involved
at the data
lowest-level granular level and what we
did is obviously we provided as I
mentioned something a key to si P is
processing governance so we provided the
governance framework and the management
of that data pro data data flows and
data controls it's not only about did
you look at it I can now tell you did
you have the right to look at it with
these authorizations but did you have
the right usage kit base for that use
you know because just because you can
you look at a social security number
because you're in payroll why are you
doing this from within another function
so all of those kind of governance
frameworks is what I say peace good at
and that's what we provided and that's a
like I say the I think you saw that on
the keynote today with burnt first
iteration was released and we're working
on I'm not sure when the next release
level is for the data custodian another
use case that I actually worked with
with the Google team for sapphire was to
take a concept of an existing sa P base
flow which is all about a fashion retail
that requires high touch interaction
with a customer and seeing if we can now
leverage the machine learning algorithms
inside the cloud machine library
learning library engine sorry in real
time to interact with a store associate
so the concept here was that most
marketing engines including sa PS we can
you know derive a propensity to buy
factor we identify based on your
interactions and your demographics you
probably have a high propensity to buy
this particular product the next one we
actually worked with the customer was
can I say well which channel should I
offer this product to the customer vie
with who should do it it should it be
interactive should it be via social
media etc so that's where they became a
conversation and what we ended up doing
was to say that hey wouldn't it be great
if we can actually find a model that
allows us to do a prediction and that
model that we actually started with is
actually the YouTube recommendation
engine so we actually use that and we
tweaked it to create a scenario and this
is what I've just just a very short
video that I've got is to show what
we're going to have here is
basically this is whoops sorry this is
the propensity to buy aspect so we've
the CRM system has created a list of
products and customers and said hey this
is what we think then the scenario can
see here what we can have on the right
hand side say a sign or you'll see that
when when I click on that it goes out
now what it's doing is actually that is
a live call that we did to the CM le
engine where we passed it all and we
trained it based on the historical
information of the sales information and
then also what we added to that to make
the model you know better is we actually
added in a function because our
assumption going in was generally
speaking that an associate will probably
sell have a higher success rate selling
or offering a product that they
personally think is really good and they
like so what we did is we incorporated
this scenario where the associates will
be like yeah I like that or I don't like
that so we were using that function now
into the training model as a in addition
to just who sold what in the past
historical scenario to arrive I will be
calling a seller affinity model and
again and the last part of this is the
part of the integration is we we did
that we ran the model and we're actually
Tralee
crawling it through and the last part of
this is to leverage the si B cloud
Leonardo analytics is to put that
remember on my HANA one there's a
there's a nice feedback loop right we
wanted to see if what we're suggesting
our hypothesis is correct so as we get
actually run the scenario we're gonna
run with the analytics to say okay
here's all the the ML assigned
assignments and here's the assignments
like this were fed through as is so
that's really the way that we're looking
at extending our capabilities in the
world in the workplace for
this is a conceptual flow of what we did
here just give you a quick idea and this
is where we're really looking at the you
know the ML functions being used in the
application tier the the thing that
we've got planned for is as part of
those action lists that came out from
that affinity model the fact that we
have within the machine learning
foundation from the cloud platform you
have the ability to now to do resource
leveling you can even factor in not only
sell this product to that particular
customer but you can actually now factor
in information regarding profitability
and pricing because we've got access to
all of our retail information and
inventory information inside Leonardo
now I can provide the call out to the
Google engine with additional factors to
improve the model can result sets coming
back
ie you can tweak the price X Y C because
I've got a lot of this in stock or it's
a much keep it up full price because
everybody in social media is after the
same product so all of those aspects are
built in but we haven't exposed that yet
because that's a business use case it's
that's the really the power of what our
cloud platform is doing versus just a
native call straight out to the Google
ml engine because we can now provide
that business context right there in in
inside and against as I mentioned this
is the actual Python that's making the
call to that session because I did say
it's a dev session the other one that
wanted a highlight was we have a
solution called ASAP product information
network and it's about having you know
all the material master data attributes
about consumer consumer goods and we
created this scenario to say that you
know who's got the best most likely the
image image library out there right now
and who actually exposes that image
library through an open API called the
vision API it's Google so in this
scenario we wanted to say you know I
like that chair take a picture of it and
I know people like Amazon do it does it
right now it gives you a kind like a
always a chair here all the chairs but
what we did was to find
now match that view extracting the
attributes and then messaging on our
product information network to find
actual real-life attributes like the
fact that it's got the color the texture
the like the cloth material etc so he
was matching at the business attribute
level from our product information
network and that's what this area looks
like you see here we're using quite a
few capabilities from the back end sa
piece GCP systems but again from our
point of view it's not about just the
machine learning functions that occur
out in the field it is making sure that
we provide the right business context
for the consumer
Kotori the consumption and then the
business process behind it as well so
that was just to give you a brief
overview of you know the key
capabilities and what we've done and
I've got in the slides ideas about you
know where to go and do this downstairs
on level 1s AP booth there are a couple
of hands-on tutorials where you can
actually play around with deploying Hana
on GCP use making use of the Android SDK
aspects as well so some of those are all
there and I wanted to know that because
there's this near near drinking time it
is I I want to leave some time for Q&A
aspects so I'm free to take any call any
questions because I like I said that
this was introductory people can find me
on LinkedIn if you've got it specific
questions about what the nuances are
about the enabling or any of these
technologies so I'm absolutely free to
help out
[Music]